hi everyone I'm Ashley Flores I'm part
of the artist development team at film
independent welcome this year we
celebrate 30 years of artist development
programs we have been at the Forefront
of educating championing and furthering
the careers of filmmakers Just As We Are
Tonight
I'm thrilled to welcome you all to the
2023 Sloan Salon storytelling and Tech
crafting human-centered stories about
technology
we are honored to host this event in
partnership with the Alfred P Sloan
Foundation which encourages artists to
create more realistic and accurate
stories about science and technology as
well as to challenge existing
stereotypes about scientists in the
media
film Independence long-standing
collaboration with the Sloan Foundation
includes a robust granting program to
support qualifying projects in short we
give out money
this past year we awarded a hundred and
twenty thousand in Sloan grants spread
across our fiction programs including
our episodic lab our producing lab Fast
Track and a distribution grant for
Finnish films
currently we're accepting applications
for our Fast Track Finance Market
selected projects will pitch up to 60
Executives over the course of three very
intense days and if you're a Sloan
qualifying project you will be eligible
to put to apply for a twenty thousand
dollar Fast Track Grant there's more
information on the film independent
website and I'll also put a link in our
chat
now it is my pleasure to introduce our
incredible moderator today Wendy Calhoun
a Peabody award-winning television
series writer and producer Wendy's
impressive career has allowed her to
explore various Realms of Storytelling
including one hour dramas unscripted
series virtual reality and gaming her
drama credits include writing producing
the first season of Fox's Empire and
debut seasons for the rookie fed
prodigal son station 19 Nashville
revenge and Justified without further
Ado Wendy Calhoun hello everybody and
happy Thursday we're almost there we'll
look at the weekend
um I am thrilled to be joining Sloan out
again and always my my pals at film
independent
um and I've got a great group of people
to speak with today I'm books I did
um I get to introduce you just like she
introduced me although I got tired of
listening to my own Reddit like what
really I didn't
um I'm going to start with hey he's
gonna let me
this is an amazing person that you all
need to know about so he's a South
korean-born American filmmaker he's
known for his Incredible video essays
that analyze the content form and
structure of various film and television
theories the essays frequently used
narration in editing as lenses and often
highlight a director's aesthetic
coconada is a regular Sight and Sound
magazine contributor and is frequently
commissioned by the Criterion Collection
to create supplemental videos for its
home video releases he's also written
directed and edited two feature films
Columbus back in 2017 and after Yang in
2021. now after Yang premiered at the
Cannes Film Festival and it starts Colin
Farrell and Joni Turner Smith and it
follows a family in a sign it's been a
Sci-Fi future grappling with their
unresponsive robotic child we're
thrilled to have you Kay thanks for
being here thanks thank you
um our another guest we have today is
ROM Layton I hope I got that right wrong
a writer and producer originally from
Tel Aviv who is now living in Los
Angeles you're probably right up the
street right wrong
um he's thrown for over a decade in the
Israeli defense intelligence working and
the Nexus of political Military
Intelligence special ops and
international relations ultimately
achieving the rank of Majors should we
call you major today
he later worked in the tech startup
industry in Tel Aviv and in his work Ron
brings fresh diverse and authentic
perspectives based on his unique
personal and professional background Ron
graduated with an MFA from USB Peter
Stark producing program and back in
Israel ROM earned a BSC in Middle
Eastern history and computer science and
an M.A in government and international
relations for which he completed his
Theses and honors with honors and
graduated magna laude so that's
major magna laude ROM is a thunder
episodic lab 2020 Alum and a bath and
newcomer he's developed shows for 20th
television studio with Spotlight off the
winner joshinger who I worked with also
with those Danny Strong who I also
worked with and he's got a musical with
ink Factory and Adina Menzel and Chris
rancano and MGM and let me tell you he
has done his work in the international
face he's developed several other things
with Fremantle and intimal Stein and
drama team in Israel Europe and Asia
welcome ROM
and we have Kareem Jeremy Kareem is our
scientific specialist here keep us on uh
on point he's a professor of psychology
at the University of Montreal he's
currently a visiting scholar at the
Brian uh brain Imaging group at USC's
and Ming how do you say this um Kareem
Ming haseen Institute it's the minxier
Institute yes Institute sounds lovely
um he holds the Canadian research chair
in computer uh how do I say this my
computer National neuroscience and
cognitive Neuro Imaging what does that
mean cream I have no idea
well he's also the director of the cubic
neural AI Research Center the unique
Center and he's a member of the Royal
Society of Canada's College of New
Scholars artists and scientists he
obtained his PhD in cognitive
neuroscience and brain Imaging from the
Pierre and Marie Curie University in
Paris and a biomedic medical engineering
degree from Germany's University of
Colorado
his research lies at the crossroads of
Neuroscience and artificial intelligence
the multidisciplinary research conducted
in his laboratory seeks to unpack the
complex brain Dynamic that meditate
higher or I should say mediate higher
order cognitive progress that's a
mouthful that's decision making and
creativity and various States Of
Consciousness think about sleeping
dreaming anesthesia meditation
psychobello psychedelic States I should
say uh he's also keenly interested in
the convergence between Neuroscience Ai
and art thanks for joining us Kareem wow
um I am so curious from all three of you
was there anything in your earliest
memories that Sparks your interest in
storytelling creativity and pet
um yeah I'm trying to think of well you
know it's funny because filmmaking
itself is is uh the incorporation is
such a technological medium
um and you know I remember this is a
weird way of of talking about it but you
know I remember being so afraid of
certain movies and it would just haunt
me and I remember my father talking uh
you know telling me that I don't need to
be scared because whatever image that
I'm thinking about that's haunting me on
the other side of it yeah was a camera
you know that he wanted me to imagine uh
this whole crew on the other side he
wasn't a filmmaker or anything but he
just understood the kind of the
deconstruction of the film and so that
that relationship between this emotional
fear that I was having and this
technology that was uh capturing it and
reproducing it was something that I I
was kind of uh worked through to uh to
try to not be so afraid you know and
it's certainly kind of uh made me
realize that this this medium itself was
technological but then that you know I
remember uh when I was a bit older I
read
um two books like Marshall mcluhan you
know when he said the medium is a
message or the massage you know it was
the first time I thought wow it's not
just uh content but it's a technology
that shapes us you know we don't just
use technology but technology uh can
alter Us in society and then uh the
Brave New World it's not so early on but
I I thought that that had that that
story always felt really profound
because in this case technology wasn't
such a like explicit it wasn't just
about controlling but it was like
through pleasure through other things
that that seem innocent that that we
were kind of falling into a certain kind
of
um again being shaped by it in ways that
that wasn't so
um yeah explicit or or
um yeah obvious
well did you have any uh early moments
that triggered your interest in this
Arena yeah I think uh you know just to
frame this conversation Tech uh I feel
like in in film and TV usually it's
sci-fi you know science fiction and it's
like Advanced Tech that is
beyond what exists uh sometimes to
heighten the message or you know discuss
some kind of topic whether it's 1984 or
both new world or all these things right
um
and uh obviously I I loved sci-fi since
I was a young you know kid and I was
always into it I think what's really
interesting about Sloan just to give
context to people who don't know that it
kind of pushes for uh grounded and
realistic
um you know Tech and Science in film and
TV
um so obviously I have like very early
sci-fi you know Blade Runner comes to
mind or the Matrix and all these stuff
but I think what really like make My
Views when it comes when I was riding in
um it's probably uh the imitation game
the Alan Turing uh movie uh that is
actually backed by Sloan as well I think
um so you know seeing a story that is
all grounded in reality the science you
know existed at the time nothing was you
know
it's it's it now it's a weird time
because it seems like we do live in the
future and robots deliver food and you
know the AI you know tsunami and
everything
um but I think for me it was the
imitation game
it also uh took a you know A Beautiful
Mind as well I think they both did such
a you know woven such a personal threat
when it came to the science of
everything
um and we'll talk about that more soon
I'm sure but
um yeah and also you know the story of
this gay individual is a gay guy myself
like how
different the times have changed and I
think Tech as a monument is just you
know it's it's just really interesting
the you know the the angle the movie
took so I think that is for me yeah I
want to massage this question a little
bit for you Kareem because you know
obviously we're the Storyteller group
and but you're the scientist I'll say
for me you know I keep going back to
Mary Shelley Frankenstein I think that
story for me was I know that's not quote
unquote the kind of tech we may want to
put under Tech but to me it was it was
man's creation of Science and then that
science somehow taking on a life of its
own for you as a scientist when did you
start to become interested in the in
studying art and and looking at that as
a part of the research and work that you
do
um I'm that's a great question I'm not
quite sure when that started but I'd say
that as a kid I was also um super
excited about science fiction uh both
for the fiction of it but also a lot for
the science so I remember for example as
a kid I think at the age of 10 my dream
was to like build this machine that
would allow us to watch our dreams real
time as their unfold so you could
connect somebody's brain uh to this
machine and they would be asleep and
then you'll be able to watch their
dreams in real time and so it's funny
now that you know 30 years or more later
um I'm seeing things in science like
getting us really close to doing what we
call Brain decoding in other words
recording brain signals running machine
learning algorithms onto them to try and
decode the content of the thoughts uh
the brain activations that relate to
different
um activations in the brain reflecting
um
aspects of cognition of emotion of
memory and things like that so
again more more globally what I'm seeing
is that this what we used to call
science fiction
um a lot of it now is becoming so much
close to reality and this is
specifically the case for AI so that's
why and this is a part of our research
is combining neuroscience and Ai and
we're seeing these large leads forward
with AI where
um anything that maybe would have
considered maybe a science fiction movie
maybe just five years ago maybe three
years ago today is sort of like a
reality show right it's something that
already exists and the technology is
already there so it begs the question of
um what is the definition of Science
Fiction now specifically when it comes
to Ai and how how um what what are the
next steps going to be but it also means
that even these types of of narrations
are holding a mirror towards us and this
is what we see is like
I feel at least in science when we're
trying to understand the brain we're
trying to use machine learning to better
understand the brain or we're trying to
understand take Knowledge from
Neuroscience to build better machine
learning algorithms it's like a two-way
um
um let's say cooperation between or
collaboration between these two fields
of Neuroscience and AI trying to help
each other out
uh the more we do that the more we start
talking about things like cognition and
machines Consciousness and machines and
things like this and so when we do that
or creativity machines our machines able
to be creative when we start asking
these questions we start to realize that
our definitions of these things are not
really quite clear to us what does it
mean to be conscious what does it mean
really truly to be creative how do we
Define that now that can that can
machine have it and so people say well
if you're asking well Define it first or
if you're saying can a machine become
conscious well let's define what
Consciousness is and that's where we
realize we have a very loose definition
of all of these things we thought we
knew but now this technology is like is
pushing us away it's like holding a
mirror towards us where we now
self-reflecting on these things and I
think there's a lot of these things that
are going to make their way into uh
storytelling and filmmaking more and
more I'm not sure this answers your
initial question but this is what I feel
very excited about these days well I
love the the analogy of holding a mirror
because that is to me is very much a
clear definition of what we as
storytellers do right holding up a
mirror to our skeletons into society
into the things that we want to reflect
and the art um and I'm so curious though
because when you think about technology
what we have up until now and I I agree
with you we are moving into a new era
that's going to require a new level of
vision for us as filmmakers as creators
as storytellers but when we think about
technology very often
the tech is presented as the antagonist
the tech is presented as the monster all
right Frankenstein the tech is presented
to us as the thing we should fear and
there's a lot of that now you know you
can hear a lot of that about AI in the
media you know they're really it's being
portrayed as this thing that we must
somehow harness and yet that we fill the
Genies out of the out of the bottle so
I'm curious from the the storytellers
here you know
first of all what do you think about the
fact that our mirror is reflecting our
idea of tech as the big bad and also are
there other ways that the reflection of
tech could be infused in story
yeah I mean I think uh what's
interesting is you know I've been uh
engaging in a lot of uh Asian and
Eastern sci-fi which has a really
fundamentally different kind of uh
relationship to let's say AI
um and in my own film too and it's funny
because I didn't think about it in
relationship to uh other Asian
literature but my instinct was uh not to
feel the other as a threat but but to
kind of have empathy and then you know
as I was reading more Asian sci-fi that
it tends to be the uh where storytelling
happens and and it's about a kind of
empathy towards this um other being and
it didn't really make me think that you
know let's say in a dominant and you
know white male narrative other
traditionally anything that's other uh
is vilified is a threat you know whether
it's a foreign person whether there it's
a some gender you know there there's
just been a real history of like
treating otherness as an immediate
threat to whatever is dominant so what
what's interesting to me so I just read
it's another beautiful uh uh Asian uh
piece of sci-fi and it was all about uh
the sort of the empathy trying to
understand the other and trying to
understand elements of it so I think as
we have other voices in The Narrative of
of uh of sci-fi and AI we may not find
that that our immediate reaction is hey
if it's other it's a threat to our
existence you know I think people who
are used to being other you know but
that their reaction is not to just
continue to other anything you know
there that they can almost relate to
that a bit and I know with after Yang
you know when I saw that it was like
this Asian robot and I know like even
being Asian feels like a construct to me
and I struggle with what that even means
you know my immediate desire in adapting
it was not to present this Asian robot
as a threat but to try to understand how
he's trying to find
um meaning you know and the emotional
element and that emotional part of AI is
is more interesting to me than and
there's some real you know I think there
are real big questions we have to ask
about it but I I you know for me it's
it's not like that I immediately see
otherness as a threat to to my existence
you know
foreign
yeah it's uh I think it really stems
from you know the person's perspective
like obviously we're all biased and I
think that is inherent to the AI
discussion uh
I don't know I mean I think Tech uh I
think I take a little bit more
philosophical
um you know I wouldn't say agnostic but
they you know sort of asking questions
approach to IT Tech I think in general
like any other tool isn't bad or good in
it of itself right it's how
people harness it use it right it's like
the same with the atom bomb it's the
same with a knife it's the same with AI
right so it's like
is it good is it bad or like who's
behind it uh who controls it and who and
for what purpose
um I think the main thing I sort of
wanted to do with my script is sort of
like
uh there's this thing that is happening
right and that was four years ago and
since then there was such a massive
explosion when it comes to AI uh with
cha GPT and everything but like we
there's this thing that's happening and
we just the public is not a part of the
discussion right so now we all know that
like wait who's what is the material
that you know the algorithm study from
and is it you know mainly predominantly
like male and white literature or coding
and right and so we have that thing it
also how do we even design the teaching
and you know all these kind of stuff
that will you know determine what the
tool will ultimately look like and then
in as a result like what it's going to
be used for right it can be autonomous
drones that are gonna
decide by themselves if they're going to
take a shot or not you know some some
anger somewhere in the Middle East
and it can be you know uh a machine that
automatically decides to you know like
in hospitals and so it's really like
questions that have such significant
impacts on our lives that we
you know we it's it's a I think what
green said about them like what is
morality and what we
um how do we code morality
um and and then like what is good and
what is bad is such big questions and I
think it's really interesting what
Covenant said about Eastern perspective
versus Western perspective and you know
the national you know nationalities and
all these sort of layers that we have as
people that
still agreeing on like
a one sort of Canon good or good you
know it's gonna be hard but um so I
think just like representation would
need to have all the variants of you
know Tech being good and bad and
you know neutral and whatnot
um
so I don't know that's some random
thoughts
yeah I mean I'll say one thing that I've
I've sort of noticed lately
um because I I I can't agree with you
more Korean like I feel like where we're
at now is the the visions of yesterday
have all called up to us and we must
start looking towards the next Vision
that and I feel it requires us to dream
you know and I'm not quite sure AI had
yet learned to dream uh I think that
might be still a fairly Human Experience
but I have noticed in more stories
lately AI being a
um inciting incident if you will or I
won't say AI I'll say Tech being an
exciting incident in the story versus
just the enemy right meaning out example
I can think of as swarm
um in the show form I don't know if
you've seen it it's a new series that's
out but basically a young woman has a
traumatic event in her life and she is
she's connected to this social media
that is sort of furring her her
character spurring her to make choices
that I'm not judging would have made
without that connection
um and I am curious to talk a little bit
about
um how Tech and I'm talking about
everyday Tech the tech we carry around
in our hand in our pocket that connects
us all
um it has had a very it has done some
very positive thing for people who
weren't heard who weren't seen who were
othered and have and brought them into
the part of social discourse that they
weren't in before because I think them
Gatekeepers may have kept them and their
stories from being heard
um do you ever think about those kinds
of things like how you incorporate Tech
into into your work into your thoughts
and the connectivity and how that could
be something in part of the artistic
expression
yeah I mean I think I I do think like
the everyday kind of tech
that you're talking about that we begin
to incorporate and you know I think new
tech is always a thing that feels scary
right but new tech eventually becomes
old Tech and then it just feels like
nothing and and I do think when it kind
of falls into nothing it's when it's
most pervasive because we're not you
know we're not like you know and I don't
want to be naive about uh Ai and new
tech because I do think it's incredibly
complicating there are all these
iterations of it but I do you know think
it is you know there's this essay I read
a long time ago called the cyborg
Manifesto but you know that we are
already all cyborgs right like we have
glass we've been using Tech to augment
our reality constantly you know we're
wearing glasses we take pills that
augment uh what you know our bodies and
so we have always kind of been uh people
who've Incorporated Tech in our lives uh
and so yeah but I mean to talk about
like these forms of communication that
uh now that they're in everyday youth
exploded and opened up possibilities and
and representation and voices that you
know otherwise wouldn't be heard
um if I could just quickly throw in one
other thing because it it it's I do
remember this old movie called The Gods
Must Be Crazy have anyone seen that
right and that I think is such a perfect
iteration like talking about it's just a
coke bottle that falls from a plane and
goes into a tribe uh you know an African
tribe and it radically changes that you
know Society like that one Coke bottle
dropped into the society and we would
never say like a coke bottle is evil we
would never say oh you know and but but
it just like in in the way in which you
know new tech will alter the way Society
functions and changes power structure
and changes you know relationships
regardless of what it is and this is
kind of the part of society this is
we've always had to
um deal with the way technology changes
relationships and Powers structures and
you know and for good or bad
yeah
maybe if I can jump in there's a related
to this idea of AI not always being on
the negative side of things and actually
maybe being contributing positively
there's been a lot of discussions as you
all know recently about the role of AI
and things like large language models
like GPT
um in in the field of creativity
um and there's a lot of debate people
say well AI should not be used to
replace human creativity and others
saying well AI could be considered
creative and so there's like these two
ideas but in the middle there's also a
third way of thinking well there might
be also new routes of co-construction on
co-creativity between humans and
machines synergistic approaches in other
words there's not a question about
humans machines replacing humans in
terms of creativity
um nor us wanting to um entirely keep AI
out of the equation when it when it
comes to to being creative but that
there might be and this this goes back
to also what Kaye was saying there's
there's we've always Incorporated
technology in different ways and in
different levels into our lives and into
our professions so um I think there's an
increase increasing this idea that for
example within the creative process of
that starts often with a Divergent
process where you're having a lot of
ideas and a lot of different options to
think about be it in in painting writing
or any other type of or Music Creation
um and then there's a convergence phase
where you have to select among all the
ideas what works best with your vision
with your idea or what's expected from
you when you try to deliver something
that makes sense in the first phase
which is the the Divergent component
um there is an increasing interest in
exploring uh the use of AI like in
generating images or generating text or
generating
um ideas that then serve as a basis for
fine-tuning tweaking changing oh no I
like this but I don't like this how
about we change this and then so you
incorporate that into the process and
then for the convergence uh part we'll
see how much AI can help but that's for
now I think remains way more
um realized a lot more in like human
intervention
um but it seems that this there might be
a third way which is like a more a
positive way of seeing things which is
synergy between humans and machines when
it comes to to creative processes I just
wanted to like highlight that other
option
in the context20 I think it's also it's
maybe it's you know obvious but it's
also really interesting time to have
this conversation especially you know
during the wga strike and the AI being
one of the
hot topics about it and you know we ask
ourselves like is it the most you know
part of the discussion and you know that
could be a part of not necessarily for
seeing the you know that obviously in
open to interpretation but just because
of what careers I think it's it's you
know kind of had had to be said
yeah hey I think we could solve the wga
crisis right now I think this panelists
I just declare my writing partner a
robot
um
um Kareem okay this one I I just have to
ask you this directly okay give us a
little secret
in your research and in your work right
now what what are you coming across are
you going why is nobody making a film
about this why is nobody telling the
story what new pockets of information
are you finding that good for some
storytelling
well I don't know so much about
storytelling but I can say one of the
things that we're looking at right now
which we're which relates to the topics
that we're discussing is trying to
um
to explore two cognitive process one is
consciousness and the other one is
creativity uh both in human brains and
in machines artificial networks on one
hand and biological networks on the
other and so for example asking the
question
um if we use tests of
um creativity like creativity scores
there are many tests that can be used to
to test human creativity can we apply
some of them to um large language models
like GPT and then how well do they score
on those tests and how well do how well
are they how fast are large language
models improving in terms of creativity
are they close to human creativity in
terms of these scores again it doesn't
mean that it encompasses all of what we
consider to be creative but on these
specific benchmarks because now when
they release these large language models
like GPT
um
they tell us how well they fare on Sat
tests on the on the bar exam on medical
license and things like this but they're
not really looking at other cognitive
cognition related tests such as a
creativity test and so we've been doing
some of this and some of the results are
quite surprising we'll we'll be
publishing on some of these soon
um but again what I find most exciting
is it so for example if you do see
performances in machines that rival or
even surpass human level of creativity
in terms of like writing or we've been
playing around with haikus is a Japanese
poetry poems that we're asking machines
to write and then we're testing how how
well they fare on that
um the question again is
what is the creative process and if we
go back to the term art which you
mentioned Wendy at the very beginning
um
what is it about art that I'm most
interested in is it the output as
somebody that looks at it and thinks
well this poem talks to me I don't care
if it's a machine or if it's a human but
actually just reading it makes me feel
something or do I need to know why who
wrote this what context what's the
background and and then that's what's
going to make an impact me and this
might differ between people I've spoken
with some of my students some of them
are quite radical incense I don't care
if it's a machine or human if I read the
those lines of poems and it makes me
feel something that's all I care about
and I have other people that I talk to
who say no for me any object of art it's
like the whole process why it became it
came to be
um and so again I'm not answering
exactly your question but I think this
is very much sort of something that
where these fields now are meeting so AI
Neuroscience or cognitive cognitive
science in particular cognitive
Neuroscience
um and the creative industry are like
sort of crossing paths now because
they're asking similar questions but
with different tools
that's fascinating I mean you're taking
me back to what you were saying earlier
okay which is like you could look at
film at itself as technology right the
medium itself that we deliver the
stories on is technology so you know
we're we're do you draw the line to say
what it is that is they know that can
evoke emotion
um
and how does Tech play Within that
yeah well I mean I think that that's I
mean that's really fascinating and well
first of all just to respond to that uh
what what um because it's really
interesting that because AI the creation
of AI is Art itself right because that's
what artists have been doing forever is
trying to you know like a sculpture and
they're trying to replicate what a human
form looks like so we're always creating
the mirror like one might even Define
art as the ultimate pursuit of like
mirroring reality and so you have
self-portraits you have a sculpture that
that takes the exact human form and in
some ways the idea that we as human
beings can create
The Act of Creation you know or really
like replicate human human beings at
such a level that they that that this
form itself can create I mean my mind is
just starting to you know like get
around that but emotionally I think
what's really interesting to me is that
we as human beings are always entangle
ourselves emotionally with objects you
know I have a you know been raising kids
and they can fall in love with a blanket
you know and when they lose the blanket
they will be emotionally uh affected by
it or you can feel that way with a car
or a sports team like we're constantly
feeling emotional about things that are
not necessarily intimate what's
interesting to me about as technology
gets more sophisticated is how
complicated that emotional uh
entanglement is going to be right and
there's real like there's real potential
feelings of loss because again even the
simplest things we can feel affect it
towards and you know Roger Ebert used to
call Cinema going back to your question
the great empathy machine that this
machine creates empathy and emotion so
it does feel like there's this
incredible intersection right now that
is happening between technology and our
medium of Storytelling and just the way
in which uh our human human beings have
more possibility of being entangled
emotionally for For Better or For Worse
in in Tech itself you know and we all
often think of tech as something cold
and distant but I think we are daily uh
engaging you know I can look at my son
and see him looking at the screen and
just smiling like responding and having
just this kind of emotion towards it
um yeah so it is like you know I mean I
think
emotion is at the heart of of our future
I think it I think we ought not to
divorce it and just think about of it
rationally I think we have to ask these
big questions about how um we will uh be
emotionally entangled you know with with
tech yeah I have a question for you
Rhonda before I forget this I mean they
talk about the dopamine hits that we get
you know just looking at you know if
they aren't social media feed is that
you know and I'm I am curious I'll come
back Ukraine about the any kind of
studies you find and the brain's
reaction to technology and how does the
brain you know uh how does it
Translate
technology do they translate it in the
same way that they translate human to
human interaction I'm curious but wait
but first
and it
about the phone Grant because you you
received a phone Grant am I right
um for your work so the question is you
know well how loose is this idea that
your your piece has to have technology
in it to qualify for that but I actually
want to know more from you about you
know which came first did you hear about
the grand thought well I want to write a
piece about technology or are you
already working on the piece about
technology this is the perfect thing for
me
yeah uh it happened kind of at the same
time I think that would be also kind of
my answer to your question about how to
evoke emotion uh when it comes to Tech
and storytelling I think uh
you know maybe I'm the a bit contrarian
on this in this uh panel but you know I
right like we get we're attached to our
phones we look at them but we you know
we get those reactions from other people
that are at their phones right it's not
the tech in it of itself the tech is
sort of right it's the ghost in the
machine it's not the machine
um I think for me uh what was really
interesting in the script I was like
okay I I I always you know character
first
um
so I think one way to evoke emotion when
it comes to Tech is like how do we take
what the tech does and we find a paradox
that is interesting with a character
that sort of had to kind of like butt
heads with
you know the profession and I
specifically
it was one of the first scripts I wrote
and I think I just moved from Israel
um to the US and obviously you know I
had my own like Notions and guilt or
like leaving home and leaving my family
and and you know sort of
always gaining distance is always an
opportunity to sort of like revisit what
you've done and um
and I feel like what if a guy that has a
really checkered morally ambiguous pest
uh is the best person to you know
program the human soul or morality or
judgment right like and that immediately
creates like wait
who made you you know be the person who
writes this and also how would you and
it's sort of an interesting debate now
it's like wait is the people you know is
is the one who committed you know are
the sinful people know but the meaning
of sin the most right or is it people
that have to be completely righteous
that you know are should should sort of
like like that path and it I this it
touches immediately I think when we talk
about creativity and
um you know and Ai and stuff will get it
just what kubernet has said about Statue
right like we this is you know it gets
to the realm of religion and God and we
all have our perspective but it's it's
sort of what we're trying to do right um
and you know in Judaism one of the Ten
Commandments is like you cannot create
an image or or you know try to create
the image or shape of God and then if
human beings are you know sort of an
emulation of God then
does AI is that as well right so I think
paradoxes are always interesting in
characters right like if what if you
know what if a misanthrop like uh like
house treats people right like
immediately it's like I think it's the
same with tech if you find like a really
piece of you know a
year I don't know like a marine
biologist that hates the sea you know
but it's immediately like oh now it's
interesting
um and the other thing I'll say uh I
think in arrival did it perfectly right
like if the tech can be a metaphors for
something because arrival is actually
based on the feminist Theory which
essentially says like when you don't
have language for something when you
don't know what something is called you
cannot Define but immediately once you
know that like oh this is
um you know like it's just even even
creating the concept of feminism now
it's like oh we understand that there's
a new power structure in society that we
didn't know of before in arrival the
whole point and sorry if I'm spoiling it
for someone the minute she understood
the
their language the aliens language now
she can suddenly speak with them because
the mind is expensive their mind is
expended
um so I think Tech either if it's an
interesting Paradox or a metaphor that
can sort of like it's like great now I'm
sort of in a in a philosophical Clash
Within Myself about what is right
um but yes you have to have uh grounded
Tech in the script uh you work with
advisors uh that to make you to like
people like um Kareem
um I had a great advisor from Duke
University uh Professor Vincent konitzer
who's also like an AI
um thought leader um
and it's fun because you know
constraints can kind of actually be very
fruitful for creativity
ah you reminded me of a story from my
own life there I mean I'm taking away a
lot from this first of all but the idea
of the mirror as something that we can
use as a metaphor to help us and create
create a crafting story with dick but
also like you're saying there's other
things I'll tell you a quick story I was
a development Executive before I became
a writer and the last the last show that
I worked on with the feature film and it
was called The Matrix
and I had a simple task on The Matrix
the company I worked for was called
Village retro pictures and they had to
decide if they were going to invest 40
million dollars in that film and if you
read the script
it did it really had a tough time making
sense of it like on paper it was
difficult but luckily the Wachowski sent
over to our offices all of their
storyboards and so I spent an entire
weekend of my life going through every
single frame every single storyboard and
I wrote up a five-page document that
went to the investors to say here's why
we should invest in this film and the
only thing I could come up with to
compare the Matrix to was God
and so in using that meant it was like
you know I have to figure out some way
to take this concept that feels strange
and odd and it doesn't make sense and
put it to a level that could reach you
know anybody on the planet how do you do
that you know and taking those broad
ideas those theme those themes and
infusing it is very helpful
um so
um that that you scream and actually um
we're gonna be wrapping up pretty soon
but I do want to make sure everybody
gets the chance to talk about this as
well
um yeah you know again some of the
things you may have discovered in your
in your studies about brains and our
reactions to technology is technology
just a barrier you know as as Ron's
saying you know it's just a thing in
between are we really just reacting to
what we're seeing or what's being
delivered on the other side or is there
something too our interface with
technology in the first part of the
question
yeah so I hope the disappointment is not
going to be too big because uh actually
we we we are in the lab we don't do
research on the specific question of
like how we how we react to technology
per se so I don't have any data on that
and you know I know some people will
just come up with wild claims pulled out
of nowhere but so I I will from a
scientific perspective I won't be able
to say much about that but
um for sure our brains are um are always
trying to like our prediction machines
and also reward seeking machines so we
try we try to find patterns all the time
that's the way we wire the brain is
wired to like try to identify patterns
uh that's also why machine intelligence
or machine learning is using a lot this
idea of like identifying patterns as how
how it how it functions and how it
learns but we're also seeking reward all
the time and so
um this is where we can get stuck in
Loops of of
um
um where where we try to do on a short
like with minimal effort something
that's going to give us Max reward and
if that works we're going to stay at it
and even in some cases there have been
experiments done I think with mice
showing that the mouse will will keep on
tapping the button for dopamine until it
actually dies just because there's this
so it's like a form of
um it's like a model of addiction in a
way that shows you like if you're
getting that rewards you can get stuck
into Loop of of wanting that so this is
also why we should probably know
technology is an important uh component
of this discussion but we should also
think of life without technology and
that's probably a good for us to be sane
but it's also probably also good for the
storytelling and narration where
um that we need a sort of a balance of
all of these things and I think for us
to thrive
um we need to be careful of like the the
negative impact of
um
yes having technology be such a central
part of our Lives
um and probably stating the obvious here
but I think it's just important to keep
like this perspective of we can I think
the way we are wired to get again to go
back to the Neuroscience side of the
things
we could easily fall into the Trap of if
the tools we have through Ai and the
applications we have and social media
allow us to get this constant rewards
um it's going to be very easy for people
to get trapped into behaviors that
ultimately are not good for them just
because it gives us immediate rewards
but actually going out for a walk or
like
leaving my phone alone for like a day or
two might give me more reward but that's
I will only realize that after two days
or after 10 day Retreat of meditation
but only after that after that time they
will realize all the good that it's
doing but Tech and some of these apps
and social media in particular have this
particularity of being able to give Us
rewards on a very short period of like
in a very short lapse so so yeah that
might be there might be a risk there
from a cognitive perspective that's
interesting you know we have a question
that's coming in and it's for the
filmmakers but I want to ask you this
too
um everyone's interested what are you
working on next what you know are there
any theories that you've got going on
that you're that you're working on that
you don't mind sharing with us or
anything any research that you're doing
right now that you're excited about that
you don't mind sharing with that I mean
I don't we don't expect you to have the
attitude we're just curious about what
playground you're playing in
is this the question to me yes it is
I'll happily answer that um obviously I
won't tell you any secrets
um so that we're looking at several
things I I I'd say first at the
intersection of of science and art we
are looking of how we can use generative
AI uh to enhance a performance or or the
way we perceive
um
let's say for example I'm just going to
make this very but we we are able now
this is amazing work that um great
students in my lab have have been doing
over the last months
um so shout out I don't know if Antoine
or Philip or
um Jan are following us but if they are
just wanted to shout out to them they've
been doing amazing work where we record
brain signals use those we try to
identify patterns using machine learning
in those brain signals and then use
those features to in real time change
um either sounds so you can create music
that is actually changed by the way your
your brain is changing at in in real
time
and in some cases we've tried this with
um short Snippets of movies so you can
you can be watching a movie but you can
actually use generative AI to create
different moods so the same movie will
be rendered differently based on how
your brain is in other words you could
say in the long term you could switch on
to a movie and then depending on you put
on your head headsets and based on how
you're feeling on that day the movie
will not be the same you should watch it
two days later the movie will be
different so sort of like uh an
interactive way of experiencing movies
or you can just remove the headset and
just look at the movie the way it was
intended for you to be to be watched but
this is something where we're seeing
some of examples of this being actually
possible so that's at the at the
frontiers of uh but on the other the
other aspects I mean we're working on
things like looking at um brain Dynamics
and brain complexity and how they change
across different states of Consciousness
including under psychedelics or
um anesthesia to try and better
understand Consciousness we look at
unconsciousness so what happens when the
brain shuts down or when when you go to
sleep or different sleep stages or what
happens during in the brain when you're
dreaming and how does that compare for
example to
um hallucinations under psychedelics and
things like this and there are metrics
such as brain complexity and a framework
called brain criticality which I won't
have time to go and delve into now today
but provides a very promising framework
to try and probe these questions and
allow us a better understanding of
what's happening in the brain when we
are in different states this can then be
extended to
to also artificial intelligence because
more and more research and computer
science are interested in importing
Knowledge from cognitive Neuroscience to
try and endow machines with some of
these capacities so how can we allow
machines to have more um for example
mechanisms of attention or mechanisms of
a better memory or emotions can we if we
have a better grip on how brain Dynamics
operates in different uh forms of
emotions or expressions of emotions
um can we build something models similar
to that that can get integrated into
artificial neural networks and if we do
is that going to make these for example
chat GPT have more empathy or will it
make it more intelligent just because
this whole debate of intelligence is not
just simply rational intelligence as
emotional intelligence so these are some
of the questions that we are looking
into right now and that I'm particularly
excited about well that's that sounds
fascinating okay what do you working on
what's coming up next
it's fascinating I love this
conversation I that I love by the way
the the reference of arrival which is
you know so like language as something
so fundamentally like language is this
sort of invention that is coursing
through our brain and shaping us and we
don't often think of that as a
technology but it is one of the most
pervasive and I think that's why we're
so started by chat GPT because it's it's
uh you know like exploring the
fundamental Tech of of all human life
which is language and then I love this
idea of like uh going back to creation
and you know in the beginning was the
word right with like this you know and
and this whole uh storytelling that
we're constantly doing kind of getting
to uh what what is the meaning of this
life you know and and that I think is
where emotion lives the stakes live
because we're all alive right now we
know that it's not forever and we're
trying to figure out what what is uh uh
what does this all mean
um anyway in my own work
um I have a film uh that I've been
working on that
I can't say too much about it but you
know it it's it's a bit romantic comedic
a little bit tragic and and but it's
fundamentally about
also thematically about truth and
artifice you know and Truth in artifice
the relationship between the two
um and then some larger project that is
um kind of in the same territory of
after Yang but at a bigger scale and
it's fundamentally and it's very uh
integrating it takes place in the future
and and it it is about
um how
um
how you know a future Tech is uh going
to affect our sense of loss our sense of
um family our sense of uh identity and
and so uh that is um yeah that's kind of
at the beginning stages of exploring
point of that what about you all
what's next I'm thinking about how do
you write the script for that movie that
changes as you go like how would you uh
you know then how the binary trees uh
look like for that um
yeah I uh I'm you know I'm hoping for
the strike uh to end as soon as possible
so uh please am PTP come back to
negotiate uh with us
um
I am actually working on a new tech
driven project but is it's very it's
very grounded it's not uh sci-fi at all
because uh by the way I think obviously
it's a Hot Topic AI but it's to say that
you know Sloan back hidden figures right
which takes place in NASA about black
women in the 60s right like it's it's
all the first female
um uh you know uh firefighters and uh
like our flight I don't know I can't
remember exactly but I'm just saying
it's a white gamut of what science is
and doesn't have to always like look
ahead sometimes it can look
um you know past uh at the past and our
time right like I I come from an
Espionage background I write a lot of
like political spy Thrillers I think you
know check there is playing a massive
part and the whole idea of
truth and online and what is then true
or not and you know especially now with
be fakes and you know all these things
uh you know this yes we kind of are
living in the future already so uh these
are things that I think about a lot uh
yeah just kind of like coconut like
Truth uh you know truth within the web
of flies uh
privacy uh if it exists still
um so these are the kind of projects
that I'm uh cooking in
I mean I mean I'm my takeaway right now
is that you know we we have this we have
this definition of text which I think
right now is all about ones and zeros to
some degree but we're talking about tech
as being something way bigger than that
I mean I've heard spiritually talk about
mushrooms you know psychophilia the
magic mushrooms as having their own
technology right so it's really
interesting I think we're gonna have to
as we move forward and I'd love to hear
your opinion maybe redefined what is tag
you know what what really is Tech does
you know the tech has to be something
that's plugged in or is it is it is it a
much broader landscape
maybe one quick comment to that I really
like what uh Kay said about language
being technology uh uh or one of the
core Technologies and in that sense it's
because language is so fundamental to
Communications to communication and also
to unders to understanding and to
defining Concepts and and to to
interaction
um so again I think to me at least
technology at the end of the day is a
tool and so it can have various forms uh
and it's it's a it's a tool that allows
us to to achieve things you know beyond
what we can just do with like without
without with our bodies uh so I think
it's a very probably a very wide
definition
um of what technology is and of course
AI is is is one of the terms that we're
talking about a lot today which is one
of the facets of Technology
but robotics uh VR are other forms of
Technologies but also medical equipment
and if anything I guess and all of these
plays such an important part like our
you know our our phones and everything
there's all the gadgets that surround us
but I really like the idea of going even
beyond that and to to case Point like
language
um is could should be concerned but also
I think uh where technology is not not
in the traditional sense but I I think
as a tool that enables us to do a lot of
things and it has evolved to uh to help
us in that sense so yeah but
yeah that's my point
yeah I uh I think I think Tech it's it's
you're right like that's a great point
and it is such a broad I mean I think
it's a really interesting time uh in
history that the first time you know
there was this uh Clarion call to stop
maybe rushing developing AI algorithms
before we understand how exactly and
what are we doing
um and who's gonna what governance
should sort of like oversee that I think
that's the first time this discussion
has been and right I think it's a really
interesting
serendipitous moment of time that in
time that um Oppenheimer is about to
come out right and like the the idea of
the atom bomb is sort of kind of echoing
to this modern times like I think you
know just because we can doesn't mean we
have to and also like why why are we
doing what we do
um so you know
yeah just as a closing comment I think
I am always still interested in the
personal element of tech and I think um
you know and I think scientists should
be uh more in the Forefront of of film
and TV film Executives screenwriters
were very like old school most of us
we're afraid of you know like I worked
with the director that uh you know he's
like yeah I don't want like in the same
computer stuff because it doesn't shoot
well like can we do Cold War you know
like uh you know dropping points and
like yeah nobody does that but so so I
think you know it's it's kind of
behooves us younger Generations that are
not afraid from computers and Tech like
to understand how we communicate that to
wider audience so they will be a part of
the conversation because it it touches
like it is relevant for us all so that
is my thought
yeah I'd like to say because of Sloan
and they they
helped Dr Yang or we got an award from
them and and I think it's such an
important it's important in this way
that the history of art is often was
kind of rooted in religion and art kind
of serving their narratives but you know
science needs narratives right I mean
I'm a real believer in science and uh
and and it can often feel cold but I
think right now in our modern world we
need to understand it in in relationship
to its meaningfulness you know and and
and I'm really grateful that there is
this sort of organization that is kind
of
um having art intersect the meanings
that they are discovering and trying to
uh you know uh incorporate into society
and so you know it's a it's it's a
really important moment for that too for
art to
um yeah you know give science the the
meaning and complexity you know that it
deserves
I agree I mean as a the writer and a
Storyteller I know that right now I'm
obsessed with something you mentioned
Kareem which is the unconscious mind
specifically the unconscious Mind of a
black woman and putting that on it's
great and then you feel what that feels
like you know and you know talk about
the empathy machine and all the other
references we've had but you know
um there's probably a way to do that
well there's many ways to do that story
um but I would imagine there's a great
way to do it that had a a level of
a level of debt that that could be a
therapy
50 years from now you know what I mean
and what would that look like and you
know how who developed that technology
and and you know who would like to shut
that technology down those are that
would be you know fascinating at least
yes I would love to see that as well and
I think just what Kareem said earlier
like we exploring the Consciousness by
understanding what is unconsciousness
and maybe it's like oh there's a story
there like you can you feel it so I
think those are the sort of like like
you know it's
this is where I think the narrative
should come from I totally agree with
you yes but I mean what you said earlier
too has a lot of validity I mean hidden
figures is a great example
um and I'm on the board of the Gina
Davis um Institute and that we use that
example all the time because if she can
see if she can be it the logo of the
whole Institute for for uh women
especially to see women working in
science they're so you mean there's just
so many stories that have yet to be told
in our history that we do need to
document in our in our for our future to
see that we there is a space for us in
science and technology meaning women and
people of color specifically
um and and that and it and I think we do
need that encouragement of those older
narrative too to let people know hey
guess what you were there you know your
your ancestry was there
um
can I say something quickly I think to
your point when the AI is is also going
to be very nice medium for storytelling
um specific to the question of
injustices and discrimination and
exclusion partly because that's in the
DNA unfortunately of current ai ai
currently so for example when we develop
algorithms people always say garbage in
garbage out if you're if you're using
garbage data your algorithm is not going
to work properly but it's also biased in
bias out so if you're using biased data
to train your algorithms your algorithms
are biased and so Ai and unfortunately
the state of AI today has a lot of
injustices embedded in its training in
its DNA it has a lot of discrimination
that is embedded in there and at all
levels and all forms and so
it is for like a science fiction or for
a futuristic type
um narration that wants to explore the
question and want to expose injustices
and discrimination and racism I think AI
is also a tool that would be great for
that to tell that story in a way that
it's going to engage also the younger
Generations who are going to be who who
might resonate more with like an AI
agent or like in an AI Persona
um created so like CGI graphic um these
generations of of of of of personas with
um with AI that has learned from the
data that Humanity has created
um it's it's I think also a very
interesting way of telling these stories
and there's a lot that can be done with
that I think
I think you're muted and this is yeah
this is my personal question
but how can we you talked about deep
Faith you mentioned the Deep fake and
yes this is a fear that we don't know we
don't know the truth from from you know
the lies from The Fakes anymore that the
lines there's going to be blurred
is there any way that we can become more
conscious of how technology impacts
um our psyche and and how to sort of
like how do we find the truth you know
what what are the things that we can do
in our thinking to help us get there
I think it's it's true as well to a you
know a headline and you know in every
news outlet and then you know is it
you know it's the fake news discussion
and like and then it becomes very
political very quickly I think we all
need to be
you know better look at you know the
news we consume the information we
consume it's it's just like AI like we
are AI is us because we code it right
like it's where do we take what do we
feed it what do we feed ourselves
um
and that's that sort of goes back to the
uh you know the good versus bad right
there's going to be Tech that creates
deep Faith there is Tech that can detect
now deep fake which is going to be like
the good sheriff and the white hat and
like it's going to be crucial to our
existence but you know
they teach in the Scandinavian kids at
you know age seven to to sort of like
discern their you know what information
they consume and how to check facts
online right like we don't talk about it
a lot in you know in this country in
Israel where I'm from you know it's
because political you know discourse is
much more heated and it's it's easy to
use you know to go to the most uh sort
of superficial level but um
I share your concerns that's uh
right I mean yeah I mean I have a 16
year old daughter who loves Tick Tock
yeah it's a topic of discussion that
comes up all the time because you know
those algorithms are very very strong
right they and and they're there to
please you to get those to get those
dopamine hits keep you engaged keep you
on there but it's also so much tied to
our capitalist system here right
um and and I've heard
um from someone who's a part of blown
I'm not going to say any names but that
even in China that there are different
regulations for tick tock and the type
of algorithms that can be used for
children that don't necessarily direct
them in the same way that we're a little
more free willing here and I don't know
that that's good you know so I think
about those things
um
I don't know if you do as a father K you
know watching your your children
engaging and wondering
you know if you you don't know what
safeguards to put up because you don't
know
what they you know what they're
consuming really yeah yeah yeah or if uh
you know if reality or everyday life can
compete with uh this dopamine you know
it is really like it Alters your taste
right so I love apples you know I've
always my my parents used to buy me like
basket of apples because I'm almost
addicted to them but you know if I'm
like just eating chocolate you know and
then I eat an apple and like apple
tastes like really Bland to me right
because it's like oh you know so it's
like you can you know I do worry that
certain things that feel meaningful in
life whether it's nature trees or other
things just can't compete with this kind
of you know stream of
um uh the sort of mediation but again I
don't want to suggest that that like you
said you suggested that it's also
opening voices and allowing people to be
heard that has never been heard and I I
think that is also true
um you know but but these are really a
deep important questions because I think
even the question of truth always goes
back to like what is truth who defines
truth and
um and you know the more fragmented we
are the more that we don't have a sense
of community or common agreement the
harder that even becomes to Define and
then to go back to science the nice
thing about science right I think I
think this rhetoric of fake news is when
you try to reduce every that there is no
such thing as truth it's just opinions
it's just you know and science you know
works at a different level of Discovery
there is a kind of accountability and
some like at least striving for
something that that becomes more
undeniable and yeah just I mean I think
we're all kind of um kind of hitting at
the notes of like this is a difficult
time and really like some of the
fundamental issues of what it means to
be human what is truth is really kind of
at stake and I think more than ever you
know we have to put science and
conversation again a conversation with
narrative you know allow that to be a
part of what people engage and consume
and hopefully want to talk about
you know in the time Kareem where we are
debating truth so much how does that
affect you as a scientist and as a
researcher and a professor
yes so I I was I was gonna say so I I
100 agree with what it what um so what
you've said Wendy and Kay also with
regards to specifically when you have
kids makes you wonder like of
um the information they've been feds
um it's also often a bubble because the
friends the people you follow is like an
echo chamber and so the same information
circulates and then it there's like a
reinforcement of your biases and so on
and and things like that but also there
might be manipulation coming going on
you don't know who's sending what
information and who's been targeting
information to send out to different
places across the world so there's all
these concerns um and I agree with them
100 but on a more of a like that's my
nature more of like an optimistic uh
point of view from a philosophical
aspect I I'm quite actually excited
about the debates that this is now
triggering in terms of asking ourselves
what is reality what is not reality when
we're talking about VR when you can have
multiple them you can spend your life
you know with a VR headset and like be
someone else live some other experiences
then you can take it off and then it's
this one and you might decide the other
one is actually more interesting for you
um who gets to say which is the reality
and then again going back to the concept
of the mirror
all of a sudden we say okay but wait
what is reality and I think Ron
mentioned this before what are we doing
here uh what what is life what is
existence and so we us we start to go
more and this I mean for some people
it's going to be very scary I'm enjoying
the push more towards
going back to these more fundamental
existential questions that we are
starting to ask ourselves right now why
is it that I'm here that I can have this
conversation with other people now on
this panel
um that I'm living this life and you
know why is this supposed to be like
yeah this is natural but all these other
things are sort of a bit weird and the
whole thing is weird
um and so
that part of it is is I can understand
it can be also a source of anxiety for a
lot of people
um but I think it can also be a sort of
at least from uh from an episode
epistemological and philosophical
perspective it can be also quite quite
quite interesting yeah I think I think
that's a great Point too because I had I
don't know if you've ever read the
literature of criticism of novels during
day you know 18th 19th century but you
know there was anxiety that kids and
yeah that when you know a more literate
culture happened and and literature
became democratized you know young
people women were like into reading
novels and people thought like oh my God
that's all they want to do is read
novels and they're not they're trying to
escape into uh reading and there is a
real concern that that was gonna that
was a crisis that a whole group of
people were not what didn't want to
engage the world and instead they just
wanted to uh fall into the world of
books but nowadays we would think oh my
God that's incredible you know my my kid
is reading books so there is that again
kind of like new technology versus
something I think for my kids as much as
it feels can feel alarming it doesn't
feel it's there it's like their water
right it's a they're swimming in it and
you want them to have some
self-reflection but it is also
um ex you know it there are other
possibilities and there they are
questioning reality in a way that I
never had a question right because
they're fundamentally addressing like
different realities and who knows what
the outcome of that might be you know it
philosophically it's fascinating you're
right it's it's in a really interesting
moment
yes maybe even they might be better than
us at identifying fake news and in
particular propaganda because these
things have always existed it's not new
but right now the technology allows very
nice examples of it that you can you can
see you can say well this never happened
but yet there's a video of it and so
we're all alarmed of it but I think
there's been a lot of propaganda on you
know multiple levels
um over the last decades
um but maybe the next generation are
going to be more aware of it and they
will be maybe less fooled by it than us
if you could go in the other direction
of course they have to be that our role
is probably also to sort of make sure
they realize this it's like at the
beginning when Wikipedia came out a lot
of people were saying well now
everybody's going to go to Wikipedia and
like half of it's going to be wrong need
to check but at the end of the day it
turns out 90 of it is actually quite
accurate and then you can do your fact
checking afterwards and check but you
can most reliably go use it and the
younger Generations are better than the
older ones that actually and integrating
information from sources like this
realizing some of the limits I I well
maybe I'm a bit too uh naive but I think
that actually works quite well
I'm just wanting to check and see what
uh what questions do I have coming in I
don't want to miss anything
here's an interesting one now this is a
big quick picture question as tools like
Holograms and AI generated realities
become widespread do you think audiences
will Retreat into inflor Worlds where
they have control over narrative similar
to gaming or what the future of shared
stories
[Music]
I love the thought bubbles we all have
thought books
well I you know I think there is a
certain pattern you know again to go
back to you know I was really fascinated
about print culture uh it appeared in my
life because you know when you can kind
of examine another era and the anxieties
and and how print really uh changed
everything right it really restructured
society and there was it was a you know
an incredible uh Revolution the print
Revolution but you know prior to print
you know people didn't read books
individually they gathered together and
you know and people you know and and
only a few people could could read and
and often uh things were read out loud
and and that's how churches you know
existed everyone didn't have their own
you know and that's how different kind
of forms existed and you know and then
you know with the rise of print it
became a much more individualized
experience and I'm sure people really
missed and I love Cinema I love
gathering in the theater I believe in it
I wanted to always remain but you know
even in my own life I find myself
watching movies just by myself and
having profound experiences you know as
much as I you know romanticize like the
theater experience you know so more than
ever I'm watching films by myself right
and and so this sort of like
individualized experience of media there
has been a history of that before and
maybe you know I I guess what does
differ though is this idea that you can
individ you you
can alter it and have a particular
experience that's not shared at all
right
um and I don't know you know I I don't
know if that is gonna I have no you know
context where I don't know if you guys
do of if that will become
you know a dominant form of content
consumption and and
you know because I do think that at the
end of the day as humans we want to
connect with other people right even if
it's at a smaller level community that
one of the best parts of art is a
conversation you could have afterwards
so I don't know what that would happen
if you only had an experience that you
couldn't talk to anyone else about you
know if you loved it or just like well
so it's so interesting that that this
person mentioned gaming because I I did
work um on a The Narrative for a
Battlefield Hardline video game and I
think gaming you know people and I've
done VR film as well and I think people
um don't realize that it has its own
Community by the way and it is very
connected it is worldwide connected and
for a lot of people that is the point of
real relief and and a gathering you know
there's not a fireplace I get it but
there's gaming and there's a console and
you are interacting For Better or For
Worse you are having a human experience
with that technology so I mean it's
I I don't know it's interesting I think
it kind of goes back to what to what you
were saying earlier about how
you know again the book are they taking
it away from the fire you know every
time we do have some new Evolution of
delivery of the story system
we we tend to keep growing with it right
it doesn't the fears the fear of the
unknown I guess that that keeps us from
not knowing and I'll be honest as I was
looking to you I felt like an old bogey
of course my daughter Kareem is gonna be
smarter than me she's only ever known a
world with an iPhone
you know for me that that's been in the
last you know quarter of my life but for
her that's been her entire life so she's
got a whole different perspective on it
and it's probably got way better
um systems in place in her own mind
about it just determine if something is
real or not or I'm probably way more
exactly easily duped
but as a fellow parent I understand this
it's good to be reminded it's good to
have this conversation because I feel
the same thing it's like oh my but
you're right it's uh yeah it's good to
be reminded that uh yeah by the way it's
a positive side yeah scientific point of
view that is another really interesting
debate like there's the ex CEO of Google
that like two weeks ago is literally
said like if you don't have kids yet
you should probably think about waiting
you know because of the AI being an
existential threat and this is think
about how surreal like this is like
taken out from uh from a Sci-Fi
dystopian and he said it right and it's
someone who's actually versed it's not
like yeah you know so so I think even in
the set you know I'm not saying if he's
wrong or uh right and I think like what
then are we as human beings if we're not
you know reproducing
um
but it's just really interesting that
now it's not just like uh an offhand
joke like this is yeah you know it's
it's a whole new world a brave in the
world that we're charting almost
um yeah
but uh yeah I think just the game video
just real quick I think it depends as
you said when it exists right there's
people that live and breathe uh their
days on Reddit or on whatever
MMORPG they're you know excited about
and there's people that you know will
hologram to their best friends
constantly and would want to use that to
connect so it's almost like
you know people are people and they have
their choices and preferences uh
I think
maybe one quick thing about
um so the point you you just mentioned
Rome about people uh so for example
these statements that some in particular
some leaders from the AI field that have
for example chosen to to leave their
company and come up with these big
statements I think
part of the problem is and it applies
specifically to AI is the fact that a
lot of the technology is so opaque and
so unaccessible to the the general
public that we look to these people and
say well if they said that and they're
in the field then probably that's the
end of humanity and so and the thing is
there's also diversity of opinions
within I can tell you this within the
computer science and within the within
the AI Community not everybody agrees
with that statement of
um if you're thinking of having kids you
probably should wait on or you should
stop all research in AI for six months
while we figure out Solutions or
something because that's I think these
are just ways I think of dramatically
um raising a red flag so that everybody
gets scared and it gets headlines
everywhere and and people pay attention
I don't believe that many and some of
these people that actually make these
statements believe them like literally
that six months of a halt is gonna like
bring Solutions and then we'll find a
way forward and you can go back to doing
AI That's not the way these things work
so they're probably making money somehow
off of saying that you know of course of
course when they say regulation is
needed and this is like it's going to be
the end of humanity we need to regulate
obviously they're looking at people that
are going to put in money and to
governments to to get all scared and
then pump yet more money into AI
um and so so yeah so but and then the
other point I wanted to mention quickly
and I think this is what you were saying
when the there's
um probably as human beings we need both
time where we're by ourselves and
experiencing things by ourselves but
also times where we where we are also in
synchrony and we're in in social
interaction so if at there are moments
where we're using VR or video games or
or or or rather AI related experiences
with other people that's great because
it's also another way of experiencing
social interaction we can be playing
soccer outside but we could also be
playing a game online and you have the
mic on and people are talking to each
other some people are actually improving
their foreign language skills by doing
these things so there's a lot of things
that are going on in these in these
environments but there are moments where
um as you were saying okay watching a
movie by yourself is probably an equally
valid and enriching experience as going
to the movie and watching it with 120
other people that's also nice none of
them is better than the other but
probably both are enjoyable in different
ways and maybe enriching in different
ways so so I think there's room for
those two things and it would be good
for us I think generally to cultivate
those two things we need to have
experiences by ourselves and but also we
actually we are social animals we
require that interaction with others
yeah I think that's true I think you
know I was just thinking about well how
would I spin that into a story and I
think you know there's something every
story we kind of play with the idea that
you start off at the North and you know
what the humanity look like as an orphan
with tech where you don't have that and
then how do you go for it you know it's
almost like a rediscovery of who we are
again as individual but then also in the
collective and what role that type plays
in along the way
um it's all really fascinating stuff
like I mean it's a bit of a rabbit hole
too because we just don't
we we don't know what we don't know I
think is sometimes how I feel about it I
hear you stay what this man said about
Ai and that we should maybe not have
kids and I think was he around in March
2020 when we could all kill each other
by blowing on each other I mean excuse
me
gigantic Global pandemic
and does he not trust Humanity that we
can't you know figure out a way to
continue our existence
with tech I'm confused
[Laughter]
I defer to him
I thought it's an interesting uh
anecdote in the context but yeah it is
it's very interesting that's a that's a
power play for sure that's a power move
to come out and say something like that
I created something so powerful
you must shut it down
you know yeah yeah
well I mean I think uh be able to ever
say that I've created a movie that's too
good take it down right
yeah I mean I think you know just going
back to our conversation like you know
technology profound technologies have
always been a part of human society and
civilization you know whether it's
language or fire and
um and it does seem like obviously and
this is a great example like I don't
think naive being naive and or just
being so optimistic that you're not
critical and ask critically engaged so
obviously the attitude is not just
uncritical acceptance or uncritical
um fear right I mean I think the the
panels like this is like really trying
to encourage critical engagement because
these are very complicated questions and
it's not as if technology you know um
Oppenheimer uh you know is is a great
example that we can create technology
that can destroy us I mean that's a
reality it's not like oh we'll always
survive we can destroy ourselves if we
don't continue to engage in conversation
and we have people who are kind of
navigating and thoughtfully uh in
engaging these issues
um but it's also good to be reminded
that the other side which is like
uncritical fear and just and all the uh
ways in which people can exploit that
fear and profit from that fear is also
not the way in which we you know uh
engage it and storytelling is a
beautiful way to kind of really invite a
conversation and maybe some of the Trap
of Storytelling is that it's much easier
to just have a hero and a villain it's
much easier to present technology as a
villain that's like a way you know it's
much more complicated to figure out what
is the structure of Storytelling that
can be compelling and deal with the
challenges of this world or what it
means to be a human not even this world
because it's constantly been like what
does it mean to be human
again I think arrival was just a great
you know ROM a great great reference
point because uh it really deals with
both the future and the past and in a
way that's just really you know
sophisticated but doesn't simplify any
of these sort of questions that we're
raising
Yeah final statement uh they went to 14
Studios and no one wanted to make
arrival before someone took a bet on it
so
yeah and I think that shows that it's
just like it's
those are such lofty Concepts that
sometimes it's hard for people that are
like brick and mortar to understand but
I think that even like you should
encourage us people who think about
these things to try and
make it more digestible just for the
sake of the critical argument as you
said it's like we should all be engaged
in this this is irrelevant
yeah absolutely as you were speaking I
was thinking about the gun you know the
gun as the piece of technology and what
has the gun done in our world how has it
shaped our world for you know since its
invention
yeah there's a good Tech story I would
watch in a minute
um
uh you know I think we are almost out of
time but I want to just give everyone a
chance to say any last words that they
may have anything else they want to
share
um and also thank you thank you thank
you for coming in and having this
discussion and for me my last words
about it is I hope that
um more people will be interested in
um engaging with tech and story and
putting those out into the world and
thinking about it even on like as we've
talked about today
higher level you know it can go beyond
what we thought to be a Sci-Fi or a tech
movie in the last century we're making
this entries and we're not and it's like
a wide open feel to what that can be so
I put that out there
um but any any last words from from
anyone
no just grateful for all three of you
this is a great conversation and uh it's
sparking you know thoughts and uh and
the people who joined us as well so
thanks guys appreciate it
okay my uh echoed the notion I also I
just want to say real quick that uh what
I love so much about uh the imitation
game for example coming to Tech right
it's about this guy who had to
constantly talking code and he doesn't
understand the world around him because
he has to hide who he is right like he's
he's gay and so that at that time right
that was crime this is why he's the only
person who could decipher the Enigma I
think there's like these beautiful like
sort of uh Confluence between like Tech
and personality and like we all we can
all ask ourselves like what is the place
of tech in our life and how does that
serve
what we don't know about ourselves and I
think that is always a good place to to
sort of start coming up with the story
yes nicely Plus
yeah I agree I think also that we should
remember that
um
Ai and all other forms of technology are
just a reflection of who we are and what
we produce so at the end of the day it's
not something that we should be afraid
of as being an entity of itself because
at the end of the day this is basically
a reflection of who we are and so and
even in engaging with AI and I hear a
lot of people talking about robot rights
now or for example the right can you if
you think that AI might have achieved at
some point Consciousness can you switch
the machine off but in these discussions
we'll we tend to forget that there's a
lot of other
obvious injustices across the planet
that we need to deal with and are
probably way more important right now
than just caring about whether a robot
should have its rights or not there are
still a lot of Wars going on that a lot
of Injustice is going on and a lot of
um discrimination that's happening and I
feel concerns trans people you know
exactly so there's a lot of a lot of
things that we need to tend to and
that's part of humanity so I think that
that's what I think we we should focus
our attention on it's one reflection and
one manifestation of humanity and what
we need to care about and like and
explore forward maybe also in our
narratives is what it means to be human
so I think that's that would be my uh my
take home and I would like to thank
everybody for this amazing opportunity I
wish we could have more of these this is
this has been a blast thank you yes
thanks everyone I hope everyone has a
great night and thanks to everyone who
came to to join us and um yeah let's
let's get to telling our stories and
really looking forward to knowing more
about your research and wishing everyone
a good night foreign